[Music]
take a walk inside this boutique and
you'll find it isn't your average
headshot Barneys New York one of
America's best-known luxury retailers is
now offering a new kind of indulgence in
their Beverly Hills store just off the
main floors with their fashion displays
is the high-end a specialty shop
dedicated to marijuana accessories and
Barneys being Barney's price is no
object
take this unique gift set from Devin Bay
a French company that once made
stationery for royalty
it's so exclusive Barney's employees
only handle it with gloves maybe you've
got an $8,000 box of rolling papers and
accessory accessories it's super special
dough and it's really thought out you
get a solid-gold
rolling tray also you get a gold temper
which you use for rolling which has the
shape of the Queen's scepter mat mizuka
is creative director at Barnabas you
know we started with 15 we're down to
four of these mizuka says the national
expansion of pot legalization finally
reached a tipping point for the company
you could see there was you could smell
marijuana in the store and you can tell
that the customers were engaging with it
could you have imagined that Barney's
would have an area dedicated to cannabis
I know I think that the voice that I've
been able to cut develop within this
company has allowed for this opportunity
to come up because you know our brand is
based on addressing cultural chefs with
far more experience in fashion
accessories than the kind used for
smoking pot Barney's needed a
collaborator to help curate the product
line they found one in bebo an la-based
luxury cannabis vendor known for their
celebrity clientele they may be the
first really classic sort of specialty
department store to do it in what I
would think is a very relevant way
because what retail needs right now is
relevance
Leslie guys is from Toby a consumer and
cultural think tank relevance is sort of
where the consumer and culture meet
and the legalization of marijuana is a
cultural moment and it syncs up really
beautifully with where the consumers
interests and instincts are right now
Barney's maybe the first major retailer
to open a cannabis lifestyle shop but
others smaller venues are already
catering to the luxury market including
higher standards without 'lets in New
York and Atlanta we felt there was a
real need for this type of store because
as legalization changes across the
country the traditional consumer is
shifting Eric Hammond is general manager
of higher standards there are
recreational uses and recreational
markets and all of these type of
consumers come to expect a much higher
level of experience in all aspects of
their life and this should be no
different Jessica Cadmus is a stylist
who created rogue pack a luxury
marijuana carrying case I was saying
toiletry bags I was saying pencil cases
shoeboxes all kinds of just sort of
unsophisticated ways to hold their
ritual I did some investigation and then
ended up designing something cuz I
really didn't find anything that I
thought was you know sort of beautiful
like Barney's higher standards found
collaborators like top home product
designer Jonathan Adler to create a line
of accessories including coasters and
ashtrays so one of the pieces is amazing
weed grinder it's $1,400 retail so and
if you think of a higher luxury products
like these dedicated to enjoying
intoxicants aren't really all that new
is this the same thing as Barney's
selling beautiful cut glassware or
liquor decanters thousand percent
especially with the culture with Los
Angeles I think people are shifting away
from maybe you know a fine wine into a
fine strain of cannabis this is the new
wine this is I you know there's so many
we did a huge exploration and survey of
of the category and there's you know
Somali A's that will you know advise on
the best strains food pairings there
really is an ever-evolving kind of
which behind this the team at Barney's
was also cautious spending almost a year
exploring what this new kind of smoke
shop would look like and how it would be
positioned for its target audience the
first place we had to start was really
understand legalities and kind of what
is permissible how is it how it was a
message what is the language of that
what do you see is the future of this
how big is this gonna get the more is
accepted and the more is he stigmatized
I think we'll see a lot of innovation
within this category